more Americans will travel for
Thanksgiving this year
triple-a predicts more than 48 million
people will hit the roads between
tomorrow and Sunday that's up almost 5
percent from last year
Airlines will also feel the strain an
industry group projects a record 30
point 6 million passengers will fly
between November 16th and the 27th mark
Elwood is a contributing editor at Conde
Nast Traveler he's here to help us get
through holiday travel stress-free
stress-free I promise best days to
travel this week and which day should we
avoid it all depends whether whether
you're whether you're driving or you're
flying if you're flying go on
Thanksgiving Day because it will be very
quiet otherwise I I'm traveling on
Wednesday and I'm a fool that's a really
busy day so is Sunday if you're driving
it's the other way around Thanksgiving
is really busy
yeah but gas prices we know are up over
since the past four years
what should consumers and drivers do to
save money on gas you need gas buddy
great app it's crowdsource so you've got
60 million users who are saying this is
the price of the gas here you just check
as you're going along you think oh if I
wait a little bit I'll get a better deal
also I would always download I exit
which is basically a lunch planner it
says - I've been next exit there's this
restaurant there's this business so it
helps you kind of plan your trip a bit I
like that one in what about ways ways is
that ways is another it's a great again
crowdsource so you're getting alerts
from other drivers that maybe there's
been an accident that hasn't been
factored in so you can reroute yourself
but if you have the app you don't get to
argue about the place you just passed if
you'd only talked about earlier before
the exit let's say you're stuck in a car
let's just say anything to do to keep
you from wanting to turn this car around
right away I'm a big fan of the analogue
map I like an old-school map and I think
now it has a bit of charm you tend not
to argue about it you kind of look at
the features it's a conversation starter
so you know break out the old maps I
think that will copy history let's say
this to you hello fellow fool because
I'm traveling on Wednesday - okay and
you said you're a fool for traveling on
Wednesday so chances are the flights
going to be delayed what's the best way
to complain effectively without acting
like a total idiot because I see people
screaming and hollering and thinking
dude you are not help
so does it ever do you ever get anywhere
by screen no no what you what you will
get something maybe well I'm certain
people for whom screaming works very
well people just become supine and it
again but you don't want to scream I
know I don't scream well I don't scream
you know that people are taking
advantage to put up your phone go onto
Twitter and tweet politely at an
airline's say hi I've got a problem
follow the airline they will then deal
with your problem privately on direct
message and then they can publicly say
we're so glad we helped you so they
basically get a PR when they show that
they helped units very quick so you blew
it over at social media now I heard
about this thing called inner lining I
heard that this morning in the makeup
room interlining is one of those
industry terms that you should know it's
essentially make nice between the
airlines it involves an awful lot of
things but one of the things it can mean
is if your flight is canceled another
airline could accommodate you so you
could end up on another carrier but
getting to your destination quicker it
won't apply in all circumstances it's
not Universal but it's always worth
again very politely asking are there any
interlining agreements that because they
just threw out the eye word they'll be
shocked that you even know that that's
now you know that another reason not to
yell at the ticket agent right and the
other reason they're all they're all
human beings celebrating or not
celebrating their of their holidays
doing their job right thank you Mark
thank you